[Music]
well hello dear friends welcome to our
program
i'd like to know this is a question and
answer program that airs live
and we would love to have your questions
sent to us so let me give you the
address
you'll notice it on the screen it's tv
at some tv dot org once again
tv at some tv dot org send us your
questions electronically and we will do
the research
and do our utmost to provide you with a
biblical
answer a solid biblical answer so
once again thank you for being with us
and taking this half hour
to be with our program and i have with
me here
james rafferty who's an associate
speaker for secrets unsealed
and i'm going to ask him to please have
a word of prayer
never should we open the bible without
prayer amen yeah let's pray
father in heaven we just want to thank
you that we can call you our father
and that we can call upon you to guide
us
by the holy spirit to understand the
word that you've given to us that you've
protected
and that you have gifted to us to guide
our steps
especially in troubles times we believe
that we are living in troubles times and
that we need your word now more than
ever and so we're asking that you will
help us
to answer these questions and to
establish
and keep our faith in your word we pray
this now in the precious name of jesus
christ
amen amen all right
i'm going to throw this uh curveball
maybe knuckleball
okay to you james somebody asked this
question based on genesis 3 verse 6
um in genesis 3 6
it says clearly that adam
is with eve but
why does ellen white say that eve
wandered away from adam
when she was tempted by satan so the
bible says that they were together
right ellen white seems to say that adam
allowed her to go astray and to be alone
under the tree so how do we resolve this
apparent discrepancy yeah i really i
think this is an important question
because uh often when we look at
scripture
and and also when we look at the spirit
of prophecy ellen white's writings
we can see apparent contradictions and
it's really important for us to
recognize that
the bible is inspired by the holy spirit
ellen white's inspired by the holy
spirit so it's not going to be any
contradictions usually the contradiction
is in our understanding of the text
right and we don't believe in word by
word inspiration
we understand that god allowed human
beings
under inspiration to write out the words
that god gave to them
and sometimes we see in phrases and in
words
and even in the translation of the
original words
some areas that causes a little bit of
difficulty and that's what i think we
have here
so if we read this uh genesis chapter 3
verse 6
it says and when the woman saw that the
tree was good for food and that it was
pleasant to the eyes
and a tree to be desired to make one
wise
she took of the fruit thereof and did
eat
and gave also unto her husband with her
and he did eat
now i think the point that's being made
here is that her husband was with her at
the tree
but we need to notice what the text says
and what the text does not say
it simply says that adam that eve gave
unto her husband with her
it does not say that adam was with her
by the tree
so so we need to allow um the text
to speak to us rather than putting
something into the text and let me just
give you an illustration
you know um you and i are at secrets
unsealed
and many times when we're here at the
office
together you're in your office i'm in my
office there'll be people that will come
in
and they'll bring us food and normally
the food is left at the front of the
office now our offices are in the back
of the office
but the food is left at the front of the
offices with the employees that are at
the front of the office
but they're with us here in the office
but the only way that we know about the
food is if they tell us about it so
they'll get the food and then they'll
get the word back to us who are with
them in the office that there's food up
front and
they'll persuade us to eat some of that
food that they may already have started
eating
and i think this is a great illustration
of what happens uh with adam and eve in
the garden
adam is with eve in the garden just like
you and i are with the other employees
in the office
but she's not necessarily in the same
place that adam is
or that eve is excuse me adam and eve
are not necessarily in the same place
so when ellen white says that eve
wandered from adam
that becomes very clear in this context
in this setting
because as you can imagine
when there as we said in the garden
together in the office together
eve is interacting with uh this serpent
and you don't see or hear anything from
adam there's there's no
there's no conversation there's no
interaction there's nothing taking place
where
there's any indication that adam is with
eve at the tree
though he is with her in the garden and
this garden isn't like you know your
apartment terrace or flat terrace this
is a
large garden with animals and trees and
so
for her to be with adam in the garden
for adam to be with eve in the garden
doesn't mean that they're necessarily
in the same location in the garden when
this takes place yeah
and we see this confirmed when god comes
to the woman you know in in genesis 3
verse 12
when adam is questioned by god the man
says
the woman that thou gave us to be with
me
she gave me the tree and i did eat and
so what is he talking about with me the
same phrase is being used well
god gave eve to be with adam in the
garden
right not necessarily by the tree so so
adam says nothing about being deceived
by the serpent
in fact he blames the woman not the
serpent
you know he says the woman that you gave
me right that's verse 17.
yes and so we know that
that adam wasn't actually with her by
the tree but he was with her in the
garden in fact
when the lord says unto the woman what
is this that thou hast done verse 13
the woman said the serpent begot me and
i did eat
the serpent begotted me and i did eat
she doesn't say the surf will be
of us and adam doesn't say anything
about being beguiled by a serpent right
and this is huge you know it clearly
implies that adam was not
with eve at the tree though he was with
her
in the garden yeah in verse 17 if i can
just read that
says then to adam he said this is god
speaking
because you have heeded the voice of
your wife
now if he was there listening to what
the serpent was saying
you know why why would it say
because you have heeded the voice of
your wife and
have eaten from the tree of which i
commanded you saying
you shall not eat of it right so that
verse clearly indicates that
you know adam was not present there
further thing
is that when you look at the roles that
god gave
to adam and eve the woman was to be
subject to the authority of the man
right the apostle paul makes that very
clear
in first timothy and also the book of
titus and first corinthians chapter 11
the head of the woman is the man right
and that's
a creation ordinance in other words
that's not something that comes in after
the fall right
so it's inconceivable that
uh eve would have
actually uh told adam
you know let's eat from this tree
because
that would be a reversal of the rules
that god established at the beginning
and you see this affirmed like you said
in the new testament you know paul says
in 1st timothy
chapter 2 and verse 14 i have the verse
here and anna was not deceived
but the woman being deceived was in the
transgression yeah so obviously
there's a different location when this
happens you know adam
knew that the woman who had been
deceived by the serpent
had eaten of this fruit he understood
the whole
scenario once it came to him right she
she would never have eaten the fruit
before adam
yes according to the the order that god
established
um and one further thing
that we need to look at in verse 6
and i'm reading from the new king james
version
it doesn't say that she was with adam
when she ate notice carefully what it
says so when the woman saw that the tree
was good for food
that it was pleasant to the eyes and a
tree desirable to make one right
wise she took of its fruit and ate
period
it's an athnak in hebrew
ate and that's a period and then it says
uh after that it says she also gave to
her husband with her
and he ate so gave to her husband with
her
in the garden it was after she ate yes
he wasn't with her when she ate
right because the headship would have
automatically given him
the uh priority to to eat first if he
was with her
by the tree so basically with her
doesn't mean
that adam and eve are going to be
together 24 7 365
right with her means the the woman that
i gave
to be with you yes ate from the tree
yeah just like i'm with you in this
office
we're here with our employees we're
together right but we have a lot of
things that come into our front door
that we don't know anything about
and a lot of shenanigans they get up to
right that we don't know anything about
until they come and tell us
when when half the goodies are already
eaten right
even though we're with them in the
office so because we're way back here
we have to keep checking we got to keep
checking and going up there right
so i'd say based on all this biblical
evidence we can conclude that while adam
was with eve
in the garden he was not with eve at the
tree when she was deceived by the
serpent
sure that eve was deceived by the
serpent and then took some of the fruit
of the knowledge of good and evil
to adam who was in the garden with her
and persuaded him to eat
i think it's very very clear when you
look at it carefully yes
you know sometimes what happens is that
people look at things superficially let
me just give you another example
you look at the the bible record of the
death of judas
you know if you go to the gospels that
says he went and he hung himself
you read the book of acts it says he
fell headlong yes and his belly split
open
and his guts came out right so people
say
see the bible contradicts itself because
clearly
those two texts cannot be reconciled
right ellen white
reconciles them beautifully she says
that
uh the branch that uh jesus hung himself
on yeah
and he was the the the largest of the
disciples
she says he was a heavy guy okay she
says that the rope
broke the branch broke the branch broke
yeah
and he and he evidently the branch was
over a ledge
and so he fell a long distance to the
ground
and his belly split open and she adds
that later that day when jesus came
with his cross in the procession to the
to golgotha
she says that the dogs were eating
judas's innards yes and so
is there a contradiction no he went and
he hung himself
but uh the branch broke yes and uh
and he said how long he fell headlong
and so
there's no contradiction the only
contradiction is in our brains
right but when we look at things
carefully we see
that there's no contradiction at all
it's so clear i mean
eve was with adam in the garden and she
wandered off
to the tree she was deceived by the
serpent she came back with the fruit
that she ate
offered it to adam and of course he
thinking i can't you know leave her
i can't be without her uh he ate of the
tree she was deceived he was not
deceived
new testament old testament perfect
correlation between the two
adam's great sin was that he loved eve
more than god
and that's the danger that we have
placed loving humans more than we love
our creator
and he could have trusted you know he
could have trusted god for for her
and we need to do the same thing we need
to trust our loved ones with the lord
amen
good okay now let's go to our next
question
uh it's asked by the same person okay
and actually this these questions are
addressed to pastor murray
but pastor murray is in panama right now
uh
his mother-in-law is uh over 100 years
old and
and so we need to pray for ca as he's
there
that he'll be able to come back safely
but the second question is genesis 7
verse 13
says clearly it's interesting that the
person uses the word clearly
in both questions yes genesis 7 13 says
clearly
in the self same day noah entered into
the ark
does the self same day mean the day
mentioned in genesis 7
11 to 12. and in other words did it
start to rain on the very day
that noah entered new york there
seems to be a discrepancy even there in
chapter seven
and the discrepancy again just to
clarify this this person has said these
two questions
uh have suffered me for many years
they've been shaking my faith they kept
me from moving forward
they seem to think that there's a
contradiction between what the bible
says and what ellen white says
because she says that noah entered the
ark and for seven days it didn't rain
right
and then finally after seven days it
began to rain and he's
looking at these texts and saying wait a
minute says the self same day he entered
it began to ring
in both cases um
and and let's just assume that he's very
sincere absolutely this person is very
sincere
they're trying to reconcile the record
of scripture with the record of the
spirit of prophecy
so how do we deal with this uh
particular issue
in genesis chapter seven um
and um you know the entirety of chapter
seven
well i think there's uh a phrase that is
used
in buying and selling real estate and
the phrase that is used
it's it's a three-fold location
location location and i think that's the
same with scripture we need to look at
the context we need to look at the
context of
the scripture in its immediate chapter
location in the larger chapter location
in the context of the bible
all the new testament and i think if you
read genesis
chapter 7 beginning with verse 1 it's
going to become
very clear i mean super clear what the
day is so we could read genesis chapter
let's just start with verse 1 and i'll
read through here to verse
the verses that he's asking about verses
11 and 12.
okay genesis 7 beginning in verse 1. and
the lord said unto noah
come thou and all thy house into the ark
for thee i have seen righteous before me
in this generation verse two and of
every clean beast thou shalt take
to thee by sevens male and his female
and of the beasts that are not clean by
two male and his female are the fowls
also of the air by sevens
the male and the female to keep seed
alive upon the face of all the earth
four here's the key verse four for yet
seven days and i will cause it to rain
upon the earth
forty days and forty nights and every
living substance that i have made will i
destroy from off the face of
all of the earth verse 5 and noah did
according unto
all that the lord commanded him and noah
was 600 years old when the flood of
waters
was upon the earth and noah went in and
his sons and his wife
and his son's wives with him into the
ark because of the waters of the flood
of the clean beasts and of the beasts
that are not clean of the fowls and
everything that creepeth upon the earth
they went in two and two under no under
the ark male and female as god had
commanded noah
and it came to pass verse 10 after seven
days
that the waters of the flood were upon
the earth in the
sixth hundredth year of noah's life in
the second month the seventh day of the
month
the same day where all the fountains of
the great deep broken up
and the windows of heaven were opened
and the rain was upon the earth 40 days
and 40 nights in the self
same day entered noah and shem and ham
and japheth and the sons of noah know
his wife and the three wives and his
sons
with them into the ark yeah basically
what's happening here
in chapter seven is the same thing that
happens for example
in daniel chapter four yes daniel 4
you know you have a repetition of this
dream several times yes
and when once we understand the
structure of chapter 7
it becomes very very clear it's divided
into three parts
okay the first part is god's
uh promise that he's gonna send a flood
that's the verses uh that you just read
verses one through five yep and then
verse six
speaks about the coming of the flood
when it's going to be no no
it's 600 years old when the flood waters
were on the earth right
that completes one cycle it's the
command to take clean and unclean
animals in
the birds etc god says after seven days
i will make it rain forty days and forty
night
and then it says noah did according to
god's will and then it says the flood
came when he was six hundred years old
right so that's a complete cycle
the next cycle is in verses seven
through nine okay
noah does what god commands uh it says
there in verse seven nor with his sons
his wife and his son's wives went into
the ark because of the waters of the
flood
then it mentions again the animals the
clean animals uh
this is verse eight the clean animals of
animals that are unclean of birds and of
everything that creeps on the earth
that was already mentioned in in verse
two uh
and it continues saying uh two by two
they went into noah uh
into the ark to noah male and female as
god commanded noah
and then you have a repetition of the
coming of the flood
the actual coming it says it came to
pass after seven days that the waters of
the flood
were on the earth and then it speaks
about the fountains of the great deep
being broken up
and it says in in verse 12 and the rain
was on the earth 40 days and 40 nights
well we saw that before
when god promised it was going to happen
that way so
verse 12 completes the second cycle
now we're going to have a third cycle
that's going to go over the same
material all over again
and that begins in verse 13. it says
on the very same day noah and noah's
sons shem ham and japheth and noah's
wife
and the three wives of the sons with
them entered the ark and then it speaks
about all the animals
of his kind etc and then from verse 17
to verse 24
it speaks about the flood actually
coming yes so and the details
yeah so so once you understand
the structure of the chapter yes it
becomes very simple to understand the
issue of the seven days
that passed before the flood came
and you know it's not only true of
studying the structure of genesis 7 it's
also
very important to understand the
structure for example of daniel
revelation yes
you know if you don't understand the
structure of revelation the order of
events
because it runs in cycles in cycles it
doesn't run in a linear fashion it runs
in cycles right and if you don't
understand that
you're not going to be able to uh know
where things begin
and where things and you're going to be
so confused that
you're going to give up yes actually and
but when you understand this
yes sure yes of daniel revelation
everything makes perfect sense
and daniel chapter 2 7 8 and 11 is
probably uh
understanding structure 101 in a sense
and when you take that i you know that
that basic
framework and you put it here you see
that in daniel 2
you don't dismiss the structural
implications
that are there when you get to daniel 7.
you just
daniel 7 just adds to them and daniel 8
adds to them we don't forget about what
you've already seen it's kind of like
the cycle is kind of like a washing
machine
you know in a washing machine you've got
your wash cycle
then you've got your rinse cycle then
you've got your spin cycle
then you've got another rinse cycle then
you've got another spin cycle
and the whole process isn't done until
it goes through all those cycles right
and you see the same thing in in
revelation you see the same thing here
in genesis
so you don't discard the information
that's given in these first verses
it's clear twice it's mentioned verse 4
and verse 10
after seven days the flood came after
seven days the flood came so when ellen
white says
no one's family entered in the ark and
after seven days the flood she's just
quoting scripture
right there's no contradiction there
between what ellen white is saying
and what the scripture is saying right
and some people say yeah but
the bible says seven days ellen white
said
that on the eighth day that
clouds were seen and so on but the
problem is they don't read carefully
because it says after
seven days which doesn't include the day
right when
it's being spoken out right uh and that
that's underlined in verse four
where it says for after seven more days
seven more days yes and then verse 10
says and it came to pass
after seven days so that would be on the
eighth day
and this is the type of thing that shows
me that ellen white was inspired
yes she didn't make the mistake and say
oh seven days you don't read
superficially
she actually says the eighth day which
is chronologically correct
and i really appreciate this because it
also shows us doesn't it that she was a
bible scholar
you know our pioneers were bible
scholars they were in the word and i
think a lot of these questions come
because we don't understand clearly the
word of god we're not
we're not studying the word of god as we
need to but i think as you said earlier
this is an honest question this
has comes from someone who's been
struggling and now i'm hoping that as we
go back and we read this in its context
and we really flush out what it's saying
here
that that struggle will be over that
they'll see the compatibility between
what the bible is saying and what ellen
white has told us time and again
i have found statements in ellen white
that i say
what where is that in the bible
and so then i go and look for it in the
bible sometimes i read a text in the
bible say
man this is puzzling let's see what
ellen white has to say
and so i it works both ways you know i
go from the bible to ellen white
and from ellen white to the bible and i
have not found
one single case where there's a
discrepancy
a true discrepancy between what the
bible says and what ellen white states
yeah and it's really the statement comes
back to me again and again over the
years it's come back to me that where
ellen white says
if we would have studied our bibles as
we should
we would have had no need for right the
spirit of prophecy she's the lesser
light leading to the greater light
so it's our lack of diligence in the
word of god that has caused us to need
god to give us more light and
understanding
so that we can really unlock the
scriptures and we need to really be in
the scripture you know early writing 63
lmi says
that the bible and the bible alone
should be the foundation of
of everything that we teach god gave us
the writings of ellen white in his mercy
because because you know she says
because the bible is not understood
god has given her writings to amplify to
explain
to correct right when we go straight
from scripture
it's kind of like um you know i ask this
question
uh and this isn't exactly related to
this question although in a certain
sense it is because it's the importance
of
not seeing a con conflict between white
and the bible
you know could the jews have accepted
christ
only based on what was written in the
old testament
absolutely sure right but they didn't
right
so what did god do god raised up john
the baptist
to shine on the pages of the old
testament
so that people could see jesus the
greater light yes
so so ellen white plays the role kind of
like john the baptist
who says you know you're not
understanding the bible you're not
understanding how the messiah is going
to come so okay
so there he is behold the lamb of god
who takes away the sin of the world
so and you know an interesting point in
that is uh john the baptist didn't
understand
everything that he said about jesus and
there are a lot of things that ellen
white said you know i don't know
i haven't been shown but this is what
this is the vision god has given me you
know there were things that
even the old testament there were things
that the prophets wrote they were they
were inspired by the holy spirit and
maybe some of those things that they
were
they saw and they wrote they didn't
fully understand themselves
but as time goes on and the scroll is
unrolled we begin to see things
and and it's it's significant to me
because human beings even our pioneers
had interpretations that didn't
necessarily harmonize
with what we understand today you know
they're
humans and but the word of god is always
consistent and god's prophet is always
consistent with the word of god
and the reason why is because the holy
spirit
superintended the composition of
scripture
amen and the holy spirit does not
contradict himself amen
and you know the holy spirit inspired
bible writers
and they wrote down the thoughts that
the holy spirit gave them
and so because the holy spirit
superintended scripture
there has to be harmony in scripture
there has to be a unity of scripture
so our need is to be filled with the
holy spirit our need is to
have the presence of the holy spirit
when we read and of course
god tells us he resists the proud um
but he gives his grace under the humble
and so i think that
it's really important for us to have a
spirit and an attitude of humility when
we approach the bible
amen sometimes when we come to the bible
we want to find contradictions because
we
want to find reasons for disregarding
the word of god
and so we're kind of leaning that way
and i want to say this carefully but i
want to say it clearly
our natural human nature tends that way
even if we don't
think we tend that way our natural human
nature our fallen nature
tends to want to find in the bible
contradictions so that we can discard
the word of god and not allow it to be
the rule of our life yeah we say if
there's a contradiction here there must
be other contradictions too
and so we end up not believing at all
and and the reason for this i think i
just
sorry for interrupting i know we've got
to close but is because we
are as humans we are looking for a
reason to disregard what god wants us to
do
yep that's our human nature our sinful
human nature yes
well tom has flown by uh i hope that
what we've discussed today has been
useful to you and that
you've seen that there is a harmony
between the bible and the spirit of
prophecy
we have one question that we did not
answer we'll pick it up next time
once again i want to thank you for being
with us if you decide to send us a
question
send it to tv at some tv dot org you
just saw it on the screen god bless you
hope to see you the next time
[Music]
you